hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the critical but also positive
steps that James Rachel articulates in
his short piece the challenge of
cultural relativism has to do with what
has come to be called soft universalism
he doesn't use that term here in this
essay but it's often been used to
describe the stance that Rachel's as
well as many other people have taken as
a response to this this problem that
cultural relativism seems to pose and
one of the ways to go about presenting a
counter challenge you could say to
cultural relativism some push back in a
way is to focus on one of the key
premises in the argument which is that
listen different cultures different
societies across the world throughout
history they all have different codes of
ethics different codes of morality
different senses and sensibilities of
what's right and wrong and so because of
that and then all the other things
follow now the question is are the codes
that they have really that different
from each other is our other fundamental
differences things that could make them
absolutely in commence
with each other incomparable so the
question we can frame in this way is how
wide are the differences in the moral
codes that the different societies
espouse and Rachel suggests that what we
need to do is pay close attention not
just to what it is that people say is
right and wrong but why they think it is
right and wrong what arguments what
explanations do they provide we need to
look at the customs and realize that
they are a complex product of both
belief systems and value systems and it
could be that the belief systems from
one culture to the other are quite
different but the value system might in
fact be if not exactly the same at least
within the same as we say ballpark that
is having a similar structure to them so
he says often what seem to be a big
difference turns out to be no difference
at all
he says consider a culture in which
people believe it's wrong to eat cows
this may even be a poor culture in which
there's not enough food but the cows are
not to be touched such a society would
appear to have values very different
from our own think of how we treat cows
we actually have more cows than we
actually need in our society because
we're so hell-bent on beef and dairy
production if it was only you know
commensurate to our actual needs we
probably would have many fewer of them
and we wouldn't be eating them quite as
much so there seems to be a very very
big difference here now he says we have
not yet we have not yet asked why these
people won't eat cows why that's the key
term there suppose they believe that
after death the souls of humans inhabit
the bodies of animals especially cows so
a cow maybe somebody's grandparent shall
we say that their values differ from
ours no because you know we could say
well if I thought that my grandparent
was in this piece of truck I would
break this piece of chalk I would treat
it well or maybe I'm a terrible grandson
and I say ah that'll teach you a
grandparent but it would still be some
sort of point of comparison so the
beliefs are what make the difference
it's not the values that are
fundamentally different and asking the
questions why reveals to us what the
beliefs are we agree we shouldn't need
grandma we disagree about whether the
cow could be grandpa's how he puts it
and then he says the point is many
factors work together to produce the
customs are of a society not only are
the values and we could range these in
what we call a hierarchy of values not
only are the values important but also
and he here he's giving a list and this
isn't necessarily comprehensive but in
this example it would be religious
beliefs factual beliefs physical
environment so if we're in different
physical environments and we have
different beliefs about how the world
works and we have different let's call
them either religious or metaphysical
beliefs about the nature of reality and
the divine and all the other things that
go along with it it's not surprising
that then we would have quite different
conceptions of what is right and what is
wrong consider a case from ancient
Greece the Antigone when we're looking
at that play and the character of
Antigone we might view her actions is
essentially incomprehensible when she's
talking about laws of the Divine and why
she has to put dirt on her brother but
if we understand that without some sort
of burial the person who she loves her
brother who has died in combat against
his own City at the hands of his own
brother who he killed needs to have that
dirt on his body
in order for his ghost to rest a
religious belief and quite possibly a
factual belief about how you know the
efficacy of dirt or something like that
then we can understand the motivation we
can say I hide I still think that what
she's doing
perhaps may not be the right thing but I
can understand where it's coming from
and so he gives another example here
that's quite telling
the Inuit anthropologists studied them
and they thought they were you know
quite different from typical Western
mores and one of the issues was
infanticide there was a practice of
killing babies especially girl babies so
it seemed that that you know shows a
radical difference from our own society
where babies are generally cherished
although we do have examples of people
abandoning their children or treating
their children quite poorly or
neglecting them once they actually do we
have them even people who foster
children sometimes treat them horribly
but going back to this if we understand
the physical environment then we can
understand why this practice might
actually make sense and he says well
let's think about what would happen if
the Inuit did not in fact engage in any
infanticide says the explanation is not
that they lacked respect for human life
or did not love their children a family
would always protect its babies if
conditions permitted but they lived in
an incredibly harsh environment where
food was scarce and so they could not
nourish all the babies that they had one
reason was as they would nurse infants
long past the stage of being infants
into their toddler years up to four
years sometimes even longer so this
could sustain very few children the
other point in fact that he brings up
the Eskimos or the into it were nomadic
unable to farm they had to keep moving
to find food infants had to be carried
and because of that a mother could carry
only one baby in her parka as she
traveled so that meant that infanticide
would be a way to actually keep at least
one child out of the set alive why
female children why eliminate them does
that show a devaluation of the female in
relation to the
Rachael's points out that actually it
showed a equal valuation it was much
more likely that males out there doing
the hunting and fishing would die and so
if you maintained a strict equality
purport of proportion between the two
genders then you'd wind up with too many
women after a while and not enough men
so when we learn more about the
conditions in which a culture is living
sometimes it's clear that we're not
talking about radically different values
just very different environments and
beliefs so the Inuit provide a great
example of that rachel's goes on and he
says that what this shows us is that we
can talk about some values that are
shared by all cultures and again this is
what we call soft universalism the idea
is that there are universal norms but
we're not saying that they're absolutely
exactly the same from culture to culture
to culture there's some adaptability in
them but in general they're quite
similar to each other and Rachel's only
talks about three main functions here of
those norms but he doesn't preclude that
there couldn't be many others as well so
let's consider the first one caring for
the young the Inuit are in fact taking
care of the young in fact he points out
that killing babies was not the first
option typically considered adoption was
common childless couples were happy to
take a fertile couple's surplus and the
norm the value that was in play was
protecting and fostering the lives of
the young he also points out another
thing what happens if a society doesn't
do this if a society essentially preys
upon its young well after a while it
ceases to be
Society because what allows it to
continue in time is generations taking
care of generations both for you know
towards the future and backwards towards
the past the young take care of the old
the old take care of the young otherwise
you can't maintain a society or culture
another example that he gives
truth-telling as great example he says
within a society in which there was no
value on truth-telling there would be no
presumption that anyone was telling the
truth because there would be no and then
there'd be no reason to pay attention to
what anyone says if I want to know what
time it was why would I ask anyone since
lying is commonplace communication would
be difficult if not impossible in such a
society what would this lead to the
breakdown of that society you cannot
have a society that has no positive norm
of truth-telling there may be variants
about who you could lie to when it's
okay to live what it's okay to lie about
but truth-telling itself has to be some
sort of value
likewise prohibiting murder which is not
necessarily the same as saying that all
killing is illicit or wrong but
prohibiting at least some killing every
society does this and if it did not do
that you would not have a society
because you wouldn't be able to trust
anybody not to kill you he even points
out that let's say we assume we have a
society that breaks down like that and
everyone lives in a you know mutual
distrust and self-sufficiency insofar as
they gather together at all they would
have to have some prohibition on murder
not even a family could survive without
some sort of sense of let's not kill
each other and we could add other things
to this as well Rachel's doesn't but you
might think about stealing taking
property that is not your own or sexual
morality there's almost every society on
earth although it may have quite
different you know mores in you know how
people couple with each other what acts
are allowed has some rules about
who can have sex with who and who cannot
and we could go on and on and on and
think of other examples the point here
that he wants to make is that there are
some moral rules that all societies must
embrace why here's the general principle
because these rules are necessary for
society to exist the concrete shape of
the rule is going to vary from moral
code to moral code he says in fact we do
find these rules enforce across all
cultures they may differ in what they
regard as legitimate exceptions to the
rules or they may differ in where the
limits lie or who they're directed at
but this disagreement exists a growth
against a broad background of agreement
so he concludes not every rule can vary
from society to society again this
stance is called soft universalism and
it is a way of undercutting one of the
central tenets of cultural relativism
which is that everything is completely
different from one moral code to another
from one culture or one society to
another
you